In 2012, the Advertising Standards Authority
ordered a Northampton-based furniture store
in England to stop advertising its prices
as 'Sofa King Low'.
China is the world's largest supplier of Bibles:
one factory in Nanjing prints a million a
month.
10% of US electricity is made from dismantled
Soviet atomic bombs.
Over 100 billion neutrinos pass unnoticed
through your head every second.
The Queen is the legal owner of one-sixth
of the Earth's land surface.
There are enough diamonds in existence to
give everyone on the planet a cupful.
If you scaled a snooker ball up to the size
of the Earth, it would have mountains three
times higher than anything currently on the
planet.
Everybody expected the Spanish Inquisition
before they arrived, because they were legally
obliged to give 30 days' notice.
George W. Bush and Saddam Hussein had their
shoes hand-made by the same Italian cobbler.
Collectively, humans have spent longer playing
World of Warcraft than they have existed as
a species separate from chimpanzees.
Humans have collectively racked up 5.93 million
years of WoW.
The first advertising jingles were written
down in newspapers; readers were expected
to sing them themselves.